Last time we introduced the way in which the preoccupation with literary and
other forms of theory in the 20th century is shadowed by a certain skepticism.
But as we were talking about that,
we actually introduced another issue which isn't,
which isn't quite the same as the issue of skepticism,
namely determinism and other words.
We said that in intellectual history,
first you get this movement,
uh,
of concern about the distance between the perceiver and the perceived a concern
that gives rise to skepticism about whether we can know things as they really
are.
Uh,
but then,
uh,
as a kind of,
as a kind of aftermath of that movement in figures like Mark's Nietzsche and
Freud,
and you'll notice that foodco reverts to such figures when he turns to the whole
question of founders of discursivity.
We'll come back to that in figures like that,
you,
you be,
you get the further question,
not just how we can know things in themselves as they really are,
but how we can trust the autonomy of that.
Which knows,
in other words,
how we can trust the autonomy of consciousness.
If in fact,
there's a chance,
a good chance,
according to these writers,
that it is in turn governed by controlled by hidden powers or forces.
And this question of determinism a is as is as important,
uh,
in the discourse of literary theory,
as the question of skepticism there plainly inner interrelated in a variety of
ways.
Uh,
but it's more that question too rich.
I want to return today.
Now last time,
uh,
following recur,
I mentioned Marx,
Nietzsche and Freud as key figures in this sort of secondary development that
somehow inaugurates theory.
Uh,
and then I added Darwin and it seems particularly important to think of Darwin
when we begin to think about the ways in which in the 20th century a variety of
thinkers are concerned about human agency.
That is to say what becomes of the idea that we have autonomy,
that we can act,
or at least that we can act with a sense of integrity,
uh,
and not just with a sense that we're being pulled,
by our strings,
like a puppet.
Uh,
the,
uh,
in the aftermath of Darwin in particular,
our understanding of natural selection,
our understanding of genetic hard wiring and other factors makes us begin to
wonder in what sense we can consider ourselves each of us to be autonomous
subjects.
And so,
as I say,
the question of agency arises and it's in that context.
Needless to say,
that I'd like to take a look at these two interesting pack passages on the sheet
that has checkoff on one side,
uh,
and James on the other.
Let's begin with the checkoff.
Uh,
the Cherry Orchard,
you know,
is about the,
a threat,
uh,
owing to socioeconomic conditions,
the conditions that do ultimately lead to the Menshevik revolution of 1907 to a
landed estate,
uh,
and the perturbation and turmoil,
into what's the cast of characters is thrown by this threat.
Now,
one of the more interesting characters who's not really a protagonist in the
play for class reasons is a house servant named,
you'll pick it off.
And if triggered off is a character who is among other things that kind of
autodidact,
that is to say he has scrambled in,
uh,
to a certain measure of knowledge about things.
Uh,
he is full of a kind of understandable self pity.
And,
uh,
his,
speeches,
uh,
are in some ways more characteristic of the gloomy,
intellectual [inaudible] that is reflected in checkoffs text really than almost
anyone else's.
And I wanted up to quote to you a couple of them.
Uh,
toward the bottom of the first page,
he says,
well,
I'm a cultivated man.
I read all kinds of remarkable books,
and yet I can never make out what direction I should take,
what it is that I want properly speaking.
And as I read,
pay attention to the degree to which he's constantly talking about language and
about the way in which he himself is inserted into language.
He's perpetually seeking a mode of properly speaking.
Uh,
he is a person who is,
uh,
somewhat knowledgeable about books,
feels himself somehow to be caught up in the Matrix of book learning.
Uh,
in other words,
a person who is very much preoccupied with his conditioning by language,
uh,
not least,
when perhaps unwittingly,
he alludes to handle it.
Should I live or should I shoot myself properly speaking to be or not to be?
In other words,
he inserts himself into the dramatic tradition to which as a character,
he himself belongs,
uh,
and shows himself to be,
in a debased form derived from one of those famous charismatic moments in which
a hero utters a comparable concern.
Uh,
and so,
and all sorts of ways in this simple passage,
we find a character who's caught up in the snare,
if I can put it that way,
caught up in the snare of language,
uh,
to continue,
in the,
uh,
he says,
properly speaking top of the next page,
properly speaking and letting others subjects alone,
I must say everything in terms of what other discourse does and what he himself
can say,
I must say.
And of course,
it's mainly about me regarding myself,
among other things that fate treats me mercilessly as a storm treats a small
boat.
The end of the passage is,
is have you ever add buckle?
Now buckle is a forgotten name today,
but at one time he was just about as famous as awesome us faults Spangler who
wrote the decline of the West.
He was a Victorian historian,
preoccupied with the dissolution of Western civilization.
In other words,
buckle was the Avatar of the notion in the late 19th century that everything was
going to hell in a handbasket.
Uh,
the one of the texts that you pick it off has read that in a certain sense
determines him.
Uh,
is buckle.
Have you read buckle?
I wish to have a word with you of Dorchester fueled or often in other words,
uh,
I'm arguing that the saturation of these speeches with signs of words,
language,
speaking words,
books,
is just the dilemma of the character.
That is to say he is in a certain sense book and language determined and he's
obscurely aware that this is his problem,
even as it's a source of pride for him.
Turning then to a passage in a very different tone from James's ambassadors and
altogether charming character,
the elderly Lambert stressor,
who has gone to most of you know,
has gone to Paris to bring home the young Chad Newsome or relative who's to take
over the family business,
uh,
the manufacturer of an unnamed household article in it,
Massachusetts,
probably toilet paper in any case.
Lambert stressor as he arrives in Paris,
uh,
has awakened to the sheer wonder of urbane culture.
And he's rent and he recognizes that he's missed something and he's gone to a,
to a party given by a sculptor.
And at this party he meets a young man named Little Bilam whom he likes and he
takes little bill 'em aside by the Lapel,
uh,
and he makes a long speech to him,
in effect saying,
don't do what I have done.
Don't miss out on life.
Live all you can.
It is a mistake not to.
And this is why he goes on to say the affair.
I mean the affair of life.
It's as though he's anticipating the affair of Shad Newsome and not I'm the VNA,
which has revealed at the end of the text the the,
the affair.
I mean the affair of life couldn't,
no doubt have been different for me for it,
it meaning life.
Life is at the best.
Our Tin Mold,
either fluted or embossed with ornamental excrescence is or else smooth and
dreadfully plane into which a helpless Jelly one's consciousness is poured.
So that one takes the form as the great cook says,
Great Cook by the way,
it's Briana Sat,
alright.
One takes the form as the great cook says,
that is more or less compactly held by it.
One lives in fine as one can still.
One has the illusion of freedom and here's where stressors says something very
clever that I think we can make use of.
He says,
therefore don't be like me without the memory of that illusion.
I was either at the right time,
too stupid or too intelligent to have it.
I don't quite know which.
Now,
if it was too stupid to have it,
then of course he would have been liberated into the realm of action.
He would have been what Nisha and an interesting precursor text calls historical
man.
He simply would have plunged ahead into life as though he had freedom even
though he was too stupid.
That it was to recognize that it was an illusion.
On the other hand,
if he was too intelligent to as it were,
Barry the illusion and live as though he were free,
if he was too intelligent to do that.
He's a kind of an Avatar of the literary theorist and other words,
the sort of person who can't forget long enough that freedom is an,
is an illusion in order to get away from the preoccupations that as I've been
saying,
uh,
characterized a certain kind of thinking in the 20th century and it's rather
charming at the last that he says,
because how can we know anything?
I don't quite know which.
And so that two strikes me as a helpful and also characteristic passage that can
introduce us to today's subject,
which is the loss of authority.
That is to say in roller inbox terms,
the death of the author in food coast terms,
the question,
what is an author?
In other words,
the first sacrifice in the absence of human agency,
the sacrifice for literary theory is the author,
the idea of the author.
And that's what we'll concern us in this second still introductory lecture to
this course.
We'll get into the proper,
uh,
or,
or at least more systematic business of the course.
Uh,
uh,
when we turned to Hermeneutics next week,
now let me,
let me set the scene.
This is parents wouldn't have to be Paris,
it could be Berkeley or Columbia or maybe Berlin.
It's 68,
69 spilling over into the 70s students and most of their professors are on the
barricades.
That is to say in the aft,
in,
in protest,
not only against the war in Vietnam,
but the outpouring of various forms of authoritative resistance to protest that
characterized the 60s.
There is a ferment of intellectual revolt which takes all sorts of forms in
Paris but is first and foremost perhaps organized by what quickly in this
country became a bumper sticker question authority.
This is the framework in which the then most prominent intellectual and France
writes an essay at the very peak of the student uprising.
What is an author and poses and answer,
which is by no means straight forward and simple.
You're probably a little frustrated because maybe you sort of anticipated what
he was going to say and then you read it and you said,
Jay,
he really isn't the saying that in fact,
I don't quite know what it is saying.
Uh,
and,
and struggled more than you expected to,
uh,
because you anticipated what I've just been saying about the setting and about
the role of Fuko and all the rest of it and were possibly more confused than you
might have expected to be.
And yet at the same time you probably felt,
oh yeah.
Well,
I did come out pretty much in the place I expected to come out in despite the
roundabout way of having gotten there because this lecture is introductory.
I'm not going to spend a great deal of time explicating the more difficult
moments,
uh,
in his argument,
I am going to emphasize what you perhaps did anticipate that he would say.
Uh,
and so that can take us along rather smoothly.
There is an initial issue and because we're a skeptical about skepticism as we
are about anything else,
we're likely to raise our eyebrows and say,
doesn't this guy full co think he's an author?
You know,
I mean,
after all,
he's a superstar.
He's a,
you know,
he,
he's used to being taken very seriously.
Does he want to say that he's just an author function,
that his textual field as a kind of set of structural operations within which
one can discover an author?
Does he really want to say this?
Well,
this is the question raised by the skeptic about skepticism or about theory and
it's one that we're going to take rather seriously,
but we're going to come back to it because there are ways,
it seems to me of keeping this question at arm's length.
In other words,
Fuko is up to something interesting and probably we should meet him at least
halfway to see,
to measure the degree of interest.
And so yes there is the question,
there is the,
there is the fact that stands before us that this very authoritative sounding
person seems to be an author,
right?
Mean never,
never met anybody who seemed more like an author then then,
then this person,
uh,
and yet he's raising the question whether there is any such thing or in any case
the question how difficult it is to decide what it is if there is.
And so let me digress with an anecdote,
which may or may not sort of help us to understand the delicacy of this
relationship between a star author,
a person,
undeniably a star author,
and the atmosphere of thought in which there is in a certain sense,
no such thing as an author and old crony and former colleague of mine,
uh,
was taking a course at Johns Hopkins in the 1960s.
This was a time when Hopkins led all American universities in the importing a
important European scholars.
Uh,
and it was a place of remarkable intellectual ferment.
And this particular lecture course was being given by George Palais,
uh,
of,
so-called phenomenological critic.
That's one of the,
it's one of the Isms we aren't covering in this seminar.
But in any case,
Fulic Pula was also a central figure on the scene of the 60s and pull.
I would be lecturing along and there's the students had some are formed the
habit of from time to time.
By the way,
you can form this habit too of raising their hand.
And what they would do is they would utter a name,
at least this is what my friend noticed.
They would raise their hand and they would say Malarne May and Palais would look
at them and say,
maybe we exact the mall,
Moma I monavie it's,
yeah,
yeah.
And then he would go on.
He would,
he would go on and,
and continue to lecture for a while and somebody else would raise his hand and
say,
boost.
Ah,
I sees him off Pat Lacey,
Bruce Proust.
And then,
you know,
he'd continue along.
So my friend decided he,
he'd give it a try
and he raised his hand and he said,
Voltaire and pull this quad the whole
call.
And then paused and hesitated and continued with his lecture as though my friend
had never asked his question.
Now this is a,
this is a ritual of introducing names,
but,
and in a certain sense,
yes,
the names of authors,
the names of stars,
but at the same time,
plainly names that stand for something other than their mere name,
names that stand for domains or fields of interesting discursivity.
That is to say,
I mean,
pooky,
Pele was the kind of critic who,
who believed that the oeuvre of an author was a totality that could be
understood as a structural hole and his criticism work that way.
And so,
yes,
the,
the signal that this field of discursivity is on the table is introduced by the
name of the author,
but it remains just a name.
It's an author without authority simply at yet at the same time,
it's an author who stands for,
whose name stands for an important field of discourse.
And that's of course what my friend,
because he knew perfectly well that when he said Voltaire Boulay would have
nothing to do with it.
Uh,
that,
that's,
that's the,
that's the idea that my friend wanted to experiment with you.
There are relevant and interesting fields of discourse and there are completely
irrelevant fields of discourse.
And,
uh,
some of these fields are on the sides of angelic discourse and some of these
fields are on the side of the demonic,
uh,
and so,
and,
and we simply kind of spontaneously make the division discursivity discourse.
That's what I forgot to talk about last time when I said that.
Sometimes people just ultimately throw up their hands when they tried to define
literature,
uh,
and say,
well,
literatures,
just whatever you say it is,
I'm fine.
Let's just go ahead.
Uh,
are much more likely,
rather than using the word literature to use the word discourse or textual
field,
uh,
discursivity you begin to hear the slight or,
or perhaps smell the slight whiff of jargon,
uh,
that pervades theoretical writing.
It always does.
So for a reason,
uh,
this is the reason one hear so much about discourse simply because the day of
doubt about the generic integrity of various forms of discourse.
One can speak hesitantly of literary discourse,
political discourse,
uh,
anthropological discourse.
But one doesn't want to go so far as to say,
literature,
political science,
anthropology.
And so it's,
it's a habit that arises from the sense of the permeability of all forms of
utterance with respect to each other.
Uh,
and that habit,
uh,
as I say,
is a kind of,
is a breakdown of the notion that certain forms of utterance can be understood
as a d limited structured field.
And one of the reasons this understanding seems so problematic is the idea that
we don't appeal to the authority of an author in making our mind about the
nature of a given field of discourse.
We find the authority of the author instead somewhere within the textual
experience,
the author is a signal is what Fuko calls a function.
The author certainly appeared by the way,
this isn't at all a question of the author not existing.
Yes,
back talks about the death of the author,
but he doesn't.
But even Bach doesn't mean that the author is dead like nature's God.
They are there.
Is there,
sure,
it's a question rather of how we know the author to be there at firstly and
secondly,
whether or not in attempting to determine the meaning of the attack of a text.
And this is something we'll be talking about next week.
We should appeal to the authority of an author.
If the author is a function,
that function is something that appears,
perhaps problematically,
appears within the experience of the text.
Something we get in terms of the speaker,
the narrator,
or in the case of place,
the orchestrator of the text,
something that we infer from the way the text unfolds.
So as a function and not as a subjective consciousness to which we appeal to
grasp a meaning,
the author still does exist.
So we consider a text as a structured entity or perhaps as an entity which is
structured and yet at the same time somehow or another passes out of structure.
Uh,
that's the case where Roland backed and in so doing and here I want to appeal to
a couple of passages.
I want to be,
I want to have,
I want to quote from the beginning of roll on backs essay,
which I know I only suggested,
but I'm simply going to quote the passage so you don't have to have read it.
Uh,
the death of the author.
It's on page eight 74.
Those of you who have your text as I hope you do
box get birthed is while writing this,
he's writing what has perhaps in retrospect seem to be his most important book.
It's called s z.
It's a huge book,
which is all about this short story by Balzac Sakae seen,
uh,
that he begins this essay by quoting,
and this is what he says about,
sorry.
Seen in his stories are seen Balzac describing a Castrato disguised as a woman
writes the following sentence.
This was woman herself with her sudden fears her irrational whims,
her instinctive worries,
her imperious boldness,
her fussings and her delicious sensibility and quote box as who is speaking.
Thus is that the hero of the story bent on remaining ignorant of the Castrato
hidden beneath the woman?
Is it Balzac the individual furnished by his personal experience with a
philosophy of woman?
Is it Balzac the author professing literary ideas on femininity?
Is it universal wisdom,
romantic psychology?
We shall never know for the good reason that writing is the destruction of every
voice of every point of origin.
Writing is that neutral composite or bleak space where our subject,
and this is a deliberate pawn,
our subject slips away our subject meaning that we don't quite know what's being
talked about sometime but also and more importantly thus subject the authorial
subject,
the actual identity of the given speaking subject.
That's what slips away the negative where all identity is lost starting with the
very identity of the body writing.
So that's a shot fired across the bow against the author,
uh,
because it's box up position that we really,
it's that the author isn't maybe quite a an author function because that that
function may be hard to identify in a discreet way among a myriad other
functions.
Food Co who I think does take for granted that a textual field is more firmly
structured.
Then backed supposes full code says on page nine 13
when we speak of the author function as opposed to the author.
And here I began quoting a at the bottom of the left hand column on page nine 13
when we speak in this way,
we no longer raise the questions.
How can have free subject penetrate the substance of things and give it meaning,
how can it activate the rules of a language from within and thus give rise to
the designs which are properly on its own?
In other words,
we no longer say,
how does the author exert autonomous will with respect to the subject matter
being expressed.
We no longer appeal.
In other words,
to the authority of the author as the source of the meaning that we find in the
text Fuko continues.
Instead these questions will be raised how,
under what conditions and in what forms can something like a subject appear in
the order of discourse.
What plays can an occupy in each type of discourse,
what functions Canada assume and by obeying what rules.
In short,
it is a matter of depriving the subject.
That is to say,
when we speak in this way of an author function,
it is a matter of depriving the subject or it's substitute a character for
example,
or a speaker,
as we say,
when we don't mean that it's the poet talking.
But,
uh,
the guy speaking in my last duchess or whatever,
right?
It's role.
So we have depriving the subject or it's substitute of its role as originator
and of analyzing the subject as a variable and complex function of discourse.
The subject here always means the subjectivity of the speaker,
right?
Not,
not the subject matter that's you'll get,
you'll get used to it because it's a word that does a lot of duty.
Uh,
and you need to develop context in which you're recognizing,
wow,
yeah,
I'm talking about the human subject or well,
I'm talking about the subject matter.
Uh,
but uh,
I trust that you will quickly kind of,
uh,
adjust to,
to,
to that difficulty.
All right,
so with us said,
probably it's time to say something in defense of the author.
I mean,
I know that you wish you could stand up here and say something in defense as the
author.
So I will speak in behalf of all of you who want to defend the author by quoting
a wonderful passage from Samuel Johnson's preface to Shakespeare in which he
explains for us why it is that we have always paid homage to the authority of
the author.
It's not just a question as obviously Fuko and bark or I was suggesting of
deferring to authority as though the authority where the police with a baton in
his hand,
right?
It's not a question of deferring to authority in that sense it's,
it's,
it's a question rather of affirming what we call the human spirit and this is
what Johnson says,
there is always a silent reference of human works to human abilities
and as the inquiry,
how far man may extend his designs or how high he may rate his native force is a
far greater dignity.
Then in what rank we shall place any particular performance.
Curiosity is always busy to discover the instruments as well as to survey the
workmanship,
to know how much is to be a scribe to original powers and how much to casual and
adventitious help.
So what Johnson is saying as well,
it's all very well to consider a textual feel the workmanship,
but at the same time we want to remind ourselves of our worth.
We want to say,
well,
Gee,
it's not just sort of,
that wasn't produced by a machine that was,
that's not just a set of functions.
Variables as one might say in the lab.
It's produced by genius.
It's Pr.
It's,
it's something that allows us to rate human ability high and that,
especially in this veil of tears and Johnson is very conscious of this being a
veil of tears.
That's what we want to keep doing.
We want to rate human potential as high as we can,
and it is for that reason in a completely different spirit and the spirit of
homage rather than cringing fear that we appeal to the authority of an officer.
Well,
all right.
That's an argument for the other side,
but these are different times.
This is 69 and the reason,
the purpose that's alleged for appealing to the author as a paternal source,
as an authority is according to both back and Fuko to police the way texts are
read.
In other words,
both of them and c'est that the appeal to the author as opposed to the
submersion of the author and the functionality of the textual field,
that the appeal to the author is a kind of de limitation or policing of the
possibilities of meaning.
Let me just read to text to that effect.
First,
going back to Roland embarked a on page eight 77
right
mocked,
says once the author is removed,
the claim to decipher a text becomes quite futile.
By the way,
once again,
there's a bit of a riff there between backed and Fuko.
Fuko wouldn't say quite futile,
he'd say,
oh no,
we can decipher it,
but the author function is just one aspect of the deciphering process.
But bark has entered a phase of his career in which you actually think that
structures are so complex that they cease to be structures and that week and,
and,
and that this has a great deal to do with the influence of deconstruction.
And we'll come back to that much later in the courts.
But in any case,
he continues to together a text and author is to impose a limit on that text to
furnish it with a final signified to close the writing.
Such a conception suits,
criticism and criticism is a lot like policing,
right?
Criticism mean being a critic,
you know,
criticizing such a,
such a solution suits criticism very well.
The ladder then allotting itself the important task of discovering the author or
it's hypotheses,
society,
history,
Psyche,
liberty,
beneath the work.
When the author has been found,
the text is explained a victory to the critic.
In other words,
the policing of meaning has been accomplished and the critic wins just as in the
uprisings of the late sixties.
The cops when,
and this is,
you know,
again the atmosphere,
uh,
in which all of this,
all of this occurs.
Uh,
just then to reinforce this,
uh,
with the,
with,
with the pronouncement of Fuko at the bottom of page nine 13 right hand column,
the author is the ideological figure by which one marks the manner in which we
fear the proliferation of meaning.
Now this May I once again,
I mean you sort of the skepticism,
skepticism and you and says,
why should I fear the proliferation of meaning?
I want to know what something definitely means.
I don't want to know that it means a million things.
You know,
I'm here to learn what things mean in so many words.
I don't want to be told that I could sit here for the rest of my life.
Just sort of parsing one sentence.
Don't tell me about that.
Don't tell me about these,
these complicated sentences from Balzac short story.
I'm here to know what things mean.
I don't care if it's policing or not.
Uh,
whatever it is,
let's get it done.
And that if that,
of course is approaching the question of how we might,
uh,
delimit meaning in a very different spirit,
there isn't,
uh,
I acknowledge they,
the,
the legitimacy of responding in this way is that to a certain extent,
the preoccupation with what shall we say,
the misuse of the appeal to an author is very much of its historical moment.
That is to say when,
uh,
one can scarcely say the word author without thinking authority.
And one can definitely never say the word authority without thinking about the
police.
This is a,
they know this,
this,
this is a structure of thought,
um,
that perhaps pervades the lives of many of us to this day has always the
pervaded the lives of many people,
but it's not quite as hedge amount hedge demonic in our thinking today perhaps,
uh,
as it was in the moment of these essays by barked,
and,
and Fuko.
All right.
With all this said,
how can the theorist recuperate honor for a certain names like for example,
his own,
all right.
It's all very,
well,
you're not an author,
but I secretly think I'm an author,
right?
Huh?
Let's,
let's suppose someone where dastardly enough,
uh,
to a harbor such thoughts,
how could you develop an argument?
How could you develop an argument in which a thought like that might actually
seem to work after all Fuko setting himself aside.
He doesn't mention himself.
Fuko very much admires certain writers in particular.
He admires like so many of his generation and other generations,
Marx and Freud,
it's a problem.
It's a problem.
If we reject the police,
like authority of authors of who we may have a certain suspicion on those
grounds.
Well we certainly don't feel that way about Marx and Freud.
What's the difference then?
How is Fuko going tomorrow to mount an argument,
uh,
in which privileged authors that is to say figures who won sites positively and
without a sense of being policed,
can somehow or another stay in the picture?
Fuko by the way,
it doesn't mention niche of it.
He might very well because niches,
idea of genealogy is perhaps the central influence on food co's work.
Uh,
I think it's frankly,
I think it's just an accident that he doesn't mention him would have been a
perfect symmetry because last time we quoted,
uh,
Paul Ricoeur to the effect that these authors,
Marx,
Nietzsche and Freud were,
and this is Rico recurs word masters.
Whoa.
That's the last thing we want to hear.
You know that they're not masters food Fuko couldn't possibly allow for that
because plainly the whole,
the whole texture of the discourse would be undermined by introducing the notion
that it's okay to be a master and yet Ricker fields that these figures dominate
modern thought as masters.
How does Fuko deal with this?
He invents a concept.
He says there aren't authors,
they're founders of discursivity,
founders of discursivity.
And then he says it's kind of,
he grants that it's kind of difficult to distinguish between a founder of
discursivity and an author who has had an important influence,
right?
And then he talks about the gothic novel and he talks about Radcliffe's Anne
Radcliffe's.
God,
he's wrong about this.
By the way,
the founder of discursivity and gothic novel is not an radically,
if it's Horace Walpole,
that's okay.
Um,
he talks,
he talks about an Radcliffe,
uh,
as the person who establishes certain tropes and tope boy and premises,
that govern the writing of gothic fiction for the next hundred years and indeed
even into the present so that she is Fuko acknowledges in a certain sense,
a person who establishes a way of talking,
a way of writing away of narrating,
but at the same time,
she,
she isn't a person Fuko claims,
uh,
who is,
who introduces a discourse or sphere of debate within which ideas without being
attributable necessarily can nevertheless be developed.
Well,
I don't know.
It seems to me that literary influences not at all unlike,
uh,
so speaking or writing in the wake of a founder of discursivity,
but we can let that pass.
And on the other hand,
Foodco is very concerned to distinguish figures like this from scientists like
Galileo and Newton.
Now,
it is interesting,
by the way,
maybe in defensive Foodco that whereas we speak of people as Marxist or
Freudian,
we don't speak of people as red cliff in or Galilean or Newtonian.
I mean we use the adjective Newtonian,
but we don't speak of certain writers who were still interested in quantum
mechanics as Newtonian writers.
Uh,
and that's interesting in a way.
and,
and may somehow or another justify who goes understanding that the texts of
those author functions known as Marx and Freud whose names might be raised in
Pula,
his lecture class,
uh,
with an enthusiastic response as place holders for those fields of discourse.
It made it made in some sense,
reinforced Fuckos argument that these are special inaugurations of debate of
developing thought that do not necessarily kowtow to the originary figure.
Certainly debatable.
I mean,
we don't,
we don't want to pause over it,
uh,
in the case either of marks or of Freud.
Plainly,
there are great many people who think of them as tyrants,
right?
But it is,
but,
but within the traditions that they established,
it is very possible to understand them as instigating ways of thinking without
necessarily provide presiding over those ways of thinking authoritatively.
And that is the special category that Fuko wants to reserve for those privileged
figures,
whom he calls founders of discursivity.
All right.
Very quickly.
Then to conclude,
one consequence of the author,
the death of the author,
the disappearance of the author into author function is as Fuko curiously says
in passing on page nine oh seven,
that the author has no legal status and you say what?
What about copyright?
What about intellectual property?
That's a horrible thing to say that the author has no legal status.
Notice once again,
the intellectual context,
it is a copyright arose as a bourgeois idea.
That is to say,
I possess my writing.
I have an ownership relationship with my writing,
the disappearance of the author,
like the disappearance of a,
a kind of corollary,
corollary disappearance of borzois thought,
um,
and tails.
In fact a kind of bracketing of the idea of copyright or intellectual property.
And so there's a certain consistency in what Fuko is saying about the author
having no legal status.
But maybe at this point it really is time to dig in our heels.
I am a lesbian Latina.
I stand before you as an author.
Okay.
Articulating and identity for the purpose of achieving freedom.
Yeah.
Not to police you,
not to deny your freedom,
but to find my own freedom.
And I stand before you precisely and in pride as an author,
I don't want to be called an author function.
I know how to be called an instrument of something larger than myself because
frankly,
that's what I've always been
and I want precisely as an authority through my authorship to remind you that I
am not anybody's instrument,
but that I am autonomous and free.
In other words,
the author,
the idea,
the traditional idea of the authors so much under suspicion and the work of Fuko
and back in the late sixties,
the traditional idea of the author can be turned on its ear.
It can be understood as a source of new found authority of the freedom of one
who has been characteristically not free and can be received by a reading
community.
In those terms,
it's very difficult to think how a food co might respond to that insistence.
And it's a problem that in a way,
dogs,
everything.
Many of the things we're going to be reading,
uh,
during the course of the semester,
even within the sorts of theorizing that are characteristically called cultural
studies and concern questions of I have the politics of identity.
Even within those disciplines there is a division of thought between people who
affirm the autonomous integrity and individuality of the identity in question
and those who say any and all identities are only subject positions discernible
and revealed through the Matrix of social practices.
There is this intrinsic split even within those forms of theory and not to
mention the kinds of theory that don't directly have to do with the politics of
identity between those it for whom what's at stake is the discovery of
autonomous individuality and those for whom what's at stake is the tendency to
hold at arm's length such discoveries,
uh,
over against the idea that the instability of any and all subject positions is
what actually contains within it as Fuko embark thought,
as they sort of sat looking at the police standing over against them.
That's it.
That this alternative notion of the undermining of any sense of that which is
authoritative,
uh,
is in its turn a possible source finally of freedom and these sorts of vexing
issues,
as I say,
in all sorts of ways,
we'll dog much of what we read during the course of the semester.
All right,
so much for the introductory lectures,
uh,
which touch on aspects of the materials that will keep returning to on Tuesday,
we'll turn to a more specific subject matter.
Hermeneutics,
what hermeneutics is,
how we can think about the nature of interpretation and our primary text will be
the excerpt in your book from Hans.
Gail got Amar and a few passages that I'll be handing out from Martin Heidegger
and Ed Hirsch.